you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news
on today's programme as global
temperatures
tick up the uk government is criticized
for not living up to its promises
on tackling climate change how switching
to more sustainable farming techniques
could help cut carbon emissions
and pointless by name but not by nature
we meet the founder
of an online plant shop with a
difference
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show
where we track the changes happening to
our world right now
and meet those coming up with the
solutions now
9 out of 10 for ambition 4 out of 10
for policies to get there that is the
verdict of the latest report
from the independent climate change
committee which advises the government
it says that ministers have made
historic climate promises in the past
year for which
they deserve credit but have been far
too slow to follow these with detailed
plans and
delivery the committee made more than
200
recommendations including managing the
phase out of gas
boilers only building new roads if they
can be shown they won't increase
emissions
bringing forward regulations to ensure
all new homes are built to low carbon
standards and a public information
campaign
to explain to people the changes that
are needed such as cutting down
on the amount of meat we eat well the
report comes ahead of the crucial united
nations cop 26 climate summit
which the uk is hosting in november but
the chief executive of the climate
change committee chris stark
says more needs to be done before then
if government efforts are to be taken
seriously i think we have to give the
prime minister
and this government credit for setting
these ambitious targets now that has
been a big part of the last 12 months
we've set
a really ambitious set of targets for
2013 for 2035
to complement the net zero target that
we already have in the uk
but what we haven't seen from the
government is the kind of detailed plans
and how we will reach
those targets what the government seem
to be doing is looking out to
the weeks before cop cop26 to a new
strategy for net zero and they seem to
be
putting all of their emphasis on on the
production of that strategy and that's
quite
a high-stakes gamble well the
government's defended its policies and
ambition
in a statement a spokesperson said any
suggestion we have been
slow to deliver climate action is widely
off the mark
over the past three decades we have
driven down emissions by
44 the fastest reduction of
any g7 country our forthcoming
strategies on
heat and buildings hydrogen transport
and comprehensive net zero strategy this
year
will set out more of the very policies
the climate change committee is calling
for
as we redouble our efforts to end the
uk's contribution
to climate change well let's bring in
now chaitanya kumar head of
environment at the new economics
foundation
really good to talk to you there's a
pretty big
gap isn't there in that report between
the promises of the government and
delivery how large is that gap in your
estimation
well the government's climate advisors
the climate change committee
are fairly clear um they lay out a
pathway between
where we ought to be in about 14 years
and where we are now
and the gap is roughly based on existing
policies
we probably get about less than halfway
where we need to be by 2035.
so it's fairly significant the gap
between your rhetoric and reality
and there are certain bits of government
aren't there which are further off the
mark than others
that's right um the committee doesn't
hold back
in basically singling out the treasury
and uh and clg
in the ministry for housing and
communities for
really sort of being very slow on acting
on climate change and sometimes
actively blocking climate action i think
that's
quite a a charge especially with the
treasury because
the treasury as we all know holds the
burst strings for a lot of climate
action and funding
uh climate policy if treasury isn't
playing ball
then it's very difficult to see how we
will get ourselves get ourselves on
track to net zero
now there's a very long laundry list of
recommendations
um some 200 which of them do you think
could and should be implemented straight
away and indeed ahead of cop 26.
two things i'd be very interested in
personally one is on public engagement
that's been the biggest sort of missing
piece in this puzzle
we know changes have to be made but if
you don't level with people
that then we have a challenge we need to
let people adopt a low carbon lifestyle
and that won't happen
you know without government support heat
pumps electric vehicles won't subsidize
themselves
we need government intervention there
the second key recommendation i think
is how do we really support local and
regional authorities
i believe they're quite central to
achieving that serum but a decade of
austerity and lack of resources has
meant
what is an important lever in public
engagement and implementing solutions
is largely missing from the picture
chatanya kumar good to talk to you thank
you
thank you in today's other climate news
the uk firm storage and its canadian
partner carbon engineering have begun
designing a direct air facility
in scotland the companies say that the
plant will permanently remove between
five hundred thousand and one million
tons of carbon dioxide from the
atmosphere
every year it would be the first
large-scale facility of its kind in
europe
and aims to be fully operational by 2026
organisers of a new environmental
project in the yorkshire dales
say it will demonstrate how the uk's
uplands can be transformed
to help fight climate change the scheme
will re-establish peatlands
and create new woodland across 1200
hectares
of land around ingleborough to remove
and
store carbon the partnership behind the
project say
it's an important step ahead of the cop
26 summit in glasgow
due to take place in november
microsoft is being urged to use its own
video conferencing tools to keep its
corporate travel
at 2020 levels the just used teams
campaign
says that the company should set an
example to others by using its platform
teams instead of asking u.s employees to
fly to face-to-face meetings
campaigners claim microsoft employees
have their own
check-in lane at seattle airport
microsoft says it's committed to become
carbon negative by 2030.
and a remote uk overseas territory will
be given protected status to conserve
its wildlife
it will cover the entire area of south
georgia and the south
sandwich islands nearly 1500 square
miles
home to seabirds seals and vast colonies
of
penguins its government says it will
focus on preserving the island's
ecosystems
and protect biodiversity this week
thousands of farmers are coming together
to discuss innovative ways to make
farming more sustainable
and to help address climate change
globally it's estimated that
20 kilograms of topsoil is lost for
every
1 kilo of food produced from
industrialized farming
well that's because it relies on harmful
chemicals heavy machinery and ploughing
which damages the soil
and with more than 95 percent of our
food coming from the ground
it's vital that farmers protect and
nurture it
well they're being encouraged to move
towards agricultural methods which are
more
environmentally friendly these include
tilling farm fields less to help the
land
store co2 making use of renewable energy
sources
and planting a wider variety of crops
sustainable farming can use up to 56
less energy per unit of crops produced
and it creates
64 percent less co2 emissions per
hectare of land
one person who knows what a difference
sustainable farming can make is
thomasina myers
she's co-founder of the restaurant chain
oaxaca which was certified
carbon neutral in 2016 and
aims to use products from regenerative
farming thomasina good to talk to you
you must have to do a lot of work to
check out
exactly where your ingredients are
coming from
and what methods they use
yeah i mean that's a huge part of what
we do because we believe it's so
important
to put incredible ingredients on our
plates
not just because we believe it's vital
to support these farmers
who can play such a huge part in
mitigating climate change
and helping the government meet those
carbon targets but also because we
really believe that that food that they
produce
in better soil has way more nutrition in
it than
food producing these more conventional
methods
which are so bad for soil erosion the
soil that those
methods use is really depleted in
nutrition um as opposed to
you know healthy soil which really does
produce better food
we were saying in the introduction there
you went carbon neutral
back in 2016 that's before many other
restauranteurs i'd imagine
were on board what were the biggest
challenges for taking that path back
then
so i think actually it's been a
wonderful journey we've worked with
we work across our board from uh from
how we build our restaurants how we
recycle our materials
we recycle our food waste we take the
hot or
air from our fridges and freezes and
divert it heat up our hot water
so there's actually really lovely kind
of fun ways you can mitigate climate
change
in that way and then you know in terms
of offsetting carbon
there are really great projects you can
get on board and we try and make ours
back to mexico where we can i think the
great piece here is that if the
government is clever farmers can be such
a huge part
in climate mitigation because healthy
soil stores
huge amounts of carbon we're talking
about the rainforest
you know equalizing so we can't grow
rainforests here but we can have really
brilliantly healthy soil
and with the government's new food
strategy if they can really get behind
us
the farmers to help them do the the best
thing
these farmers want to do the best thing
they want to be taking their part in
creating biodiversity having holistic
farming methods where they're
diverting monoculture into you know
multicultural so they're
they're just promoting diversity helping
soil health and producing
much better food that's so interesting
talking to you thomasina myers thank you
for your time thank you
now what are your goals for the next
four years well for one former pilot
he's got
lofty ambitions to plant a million trees
by 2025. nathan rob founded pointless
plants to try and offer a more
sustainable option
for those looking to test out their
green fingers by banning plastic pots
peat-based soil and plant wastage here's
his story
welcome to my pointless plants crib
hi guys i'm nathan rob i'm the founder
of pointless plants
here is all of our plants we're on a
mission to plant
one million trees by the end of 2025 for
every order we plant
10 trees i'm 24 years old and i was a
pilot for four years
flying around spraying tons and tons of
fuel
i've seen big organizations and
companies putting profits over peak in
the planets
that really just did not fulfill me so
this is a plant i love
it's a clayton lancifolia there's a lot
of
information out there for example we
plant entries for every order
and we do this to reduce carbon and
there's always so much new information
now it looks like
algae might be a better way to produce
carbon there's so much information it's
sometimes
hard to know what the right thing to do
but i really feel like small
changes can make a really big difference
so planting 10 trees better than plant
no trees
i believe it's my responsibility to do
what i can do to try and make this
planet a greener place
that's it for today's show coming up on
the daily climate show tomorrow
our correspondent adam parsons reports
on the villages in germany
being demolished to make way for the
expansion of a vast coal mine
you can see that at the same time
tomorrow here on sky news
or watch the full show on youtube hope
to see you then
you